Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are continuing Sex-tember.
Tember!
That's when it falls.
What does the tree symbolize?
A large penis?
It's a phallus, yes.
Okay.
It's a phallus of some sort.
Just making sure we're on the same page.
Last week was great.
This week is gonna be great.
We got another guest to just
Enlighten us.
to keep us in on proper information.
Dr. Emily Nagoski, so excited about this,
is a sex educator, speaker,
and award-winning author
of the New York Times' Best
selling book, "Come as You Are",
and the "Come as You Are"
workbook and co-author
with her sister, Amelia, of the
New York Times' best seller,
"Burnout: the Secret to
Unlocking the Stress Cycle".
Dr. N., is what I'm
gonna call her right now,
That stands for Nagoski.
is director of wellness
education at Smith College,
where she teaches a course
on women's sexuality.
She combines sex education
and stress education
to teach women to live
with confidence and joy
inside their bodies.
We've actually already
had this conversation
that you're about to listen to.
I gotta say I learned a lot.
Yeah.
She instructed us to call her Emily.
That's why we call her Emily,
although she is a doctor,
and as you will see a very
well qualified one at that,
continuing to enlighten these
boys that are just hungry
to learn about sex.
If you don't wanna hear specific
and explicit talk about sex,
don't listen to this episode.
That's your warning.
Midterm elections are
coming up on November 8th,
and across the US, people
are gonna be voting
on some pretty crucial spots
in Congress, governors,
and special elections, and
we want you to vote too.
Yeah, so Vote Like a
Beast is here to help you.
Go to votelikeabeast.com.
You can check your voting status there.
You can register if you need to,
and you can stay informed
on midterm elections.
We're also selling some stickers over
at votelikeabeast.com and 100%
of our profits go directly
to our partners over at vote.org.
This is a website that
we created to help you.
So be your mythical best by
supporting a great nonprofit
that helps all Americans
exercise their right to vote.
Go to votelikeabeats.com.
I noticed that you are,
and I listened to the will
lack of sleep kill you,
by the way, yes, it will,
and you had a conversation
about Link's glasses,
and I'm wearing very similar
glasses, and I thought,
oh good.
I see that.
I'm not gonna have to
explain about your glasses,
and now you're not wearing those glasses.
Do you have 'em?
Oh, now you want me to wear the glasses?
Well, I mean,
Of course, I have the glasses.
Hold on, hold on.
I feel like making guests feel at home.
We don't always have guests.
It's just when we want
to talk about something
where we want an expert involved,
even a sexpert involved,
I want them to feel welcome.
Mmhmm.
So I wear mine because I get migraines,
and the light from my screen is a trigger,
and this filters out the
blue light that activates it.
So are yours also for medical reasons
or you just wanna look like Elton John?
Yeah, well, I can't wait for this answer.
You're wearing those for medical reasons?
Yeah, because I mean, feeling
good is medical, right?
Absolutely.
These make me feel good.
They make me feel good.
I'm glad that we're cohorts now, Emily.
Yeah, we can share this.
Look at that.
We're seeing the world in an orange tint.
I gotta say, now--
Boy, and you look cool.
I don't care about medical reasons.
You can just do it for the cools.
Can I just say that now
that this has happened,
I feel very left out.
You're damn right, and you are left out.
Hold on one second.
I'll be right back.
Look what you've done.
I feel like he's gonna come
back in year 2000 New Years Eve glasses.
I'm just mad that he was giving me nothing
but about my glasses, which
I don't care about that.
That didn't make me mad.
That's his problem, but now,
because he respects you
so much, Emily, I guess,
or wants to impress you,
he's totally switched sides.
I know he's gonna come
back with something, yep.
If nothing else happens, I
have made your life easier.
Oh my gosh.
Those are prop glasses.
You're not gonna wear those
out in the real world.
I've been meaning to.
I didn't know it was gonna
happen this soon, but.
Battle of the glasses.
I kind of feel
like I've been forced into this.
Okay, so you're making
fun of me and Emily,
because we're doing this sincerely.
No, I--
She had my migraines!
You don't think
this is sincere?
She has migraines, and I'm cool!
You never know when migraines might start.
You're not, you're neither.
I mean,
You're nothing to us.
things start happening
when, you know what?
I think
We are not the same.
we're all basically the same age.
Let's talk about sex.
Yeah, I am.
I was born in '77.
You're a '77 baby.
'77.
'78 baby.
This is supposed to be about sex.
Things start happening.
You get migraines.
I'm gonna find a way to make
this relevant to sexuality.
I'm getting so sexually
frustrated right now.
The blue balls are real.
I feel very sexy, and you know what?
Let's talk about that
a little bit because--
About blue balls?
Well, we can talk about blue balls.
Oh, we can talk about blue balls.
Are blue balls real, because--
Hold on, I was about to ask a question
before we got to blue balls.
No.
We don't care about you and your glasses.
And that is how you feel
about the way that you look
can have an impact on what
happens in the bedroom,
so to speak, right?
Oh yeah, body image and
stress are the top two things
that hit the brakes,
which I'm sure we'll talk
about the dual control model,
but body image and stress, top
two, trauma not far behind.
Okay, so yo, but to get the
blue balls outta the way,
because everything you just
mentioned is where we're going
in this podcast.
Are blue balls really a thing, because I,
or is it just something that
sexually frustrated people
with balls dangle over
others to get what they want?
I actually don't know.
I think I've experienced it.
Tell me what you mean by blue balls,
because people mean different things.
Like I am--
You talking about avatar?
My body is ready.
If things continued another,
let's say, five or 10 minutes,
then I could ejaculate or one, let's say,
let's not make this about me.
One could ejaculate.
Yeah.
One with balls could ejaculate,
and then, so physically, there's a pain
of all the soldiers lining
up to go into battle,
It's just a drill.
but yet at the last second,
it's like, you know what?
We're calling it off.
Back to the barracks.
It's just a war game.
Back to the balls barracks.
You're not coming out to
the war games, and it hurts,
No, it is war games.
And the balls don't actually
turn blue, but they hurt.
It hurts.
There is a physical
discomfort that can come
with experiencing a really
high level of arousal
and then having that stop,
especially if it stops suddenly,
and there is nothing dangerous about it.
Nobody has ever died or
even suffered an injury
Death by blue balls.
as a result of, yeah,
and the problem arises when
someone takes the discomfort
of a sudden interruption
of a high level arousal
as entitlement to orgasm
like, you have to,
cuz I don't feel, I need that.
You don't need it.
Nothing bad is gonna happen to you.
If you really need to keep going,
go be by yourself for a couple of minutes
and get the job done if you want to,
and mostly what you're
experiencing is sexual frustration,
which no one has ever suffered injury due
to sexual frustration.
Right.
Okay, good to hear.
So don't dangle the blue balls
as some sort of ultimatum.
And don't worry that next
time you get blue balls
that you might die.
Yeah, literally nothing bad
will happen to you except
that your partner, who
is like, you know what?
I'm not ready to go any further.
You can be like, okay, we can stop now,
and they'll have mad respect for you.
Well.
Let's talk.
Can we talk about the book?
Let's talk about the book.
I'm taking it back out.
"Come as You Are", this
is an amazing book.
I know it's been out for like seven years.
The fact that it, I mean, it's
a testimony to how powerful
this book is as a resource to people.
I love it.
This is our recommendation
today, "Come as You Are",
Emily's book, one of many.
What's the name of your
new book, by the way,
the stress one?
"Burnout".
Oh, "Burnout", yeah.
Burnout, we're gonna shout
out that one too, but--
Shout out to "Burnout".
So my daughter, Lily, when she went off
to college last year, a mentor
of hers gave her this book,
and I saw it around,
because I noticed the cover.
This is a brilliant cover.
I mean, it's eye catching pink,
and then there's an open
zipper that is very vulvic.
I mean, I don't know if that's
what you were going for,
but I'm pretty sure it was.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I think it's just a purse.
That's right.
That thing's gotta be on the
shelf in Barnes and Noble.
You can't be just having
a vulva out there.
This is one of the best book
covers I have ever seen,
but I gotta be honest.
I'm glad you like it.
There's a dark side to it.
It's a little visceral when you think
about putting your wiener in a some,
Something that can zip.
something that can zip up.
I get a little something
about marry promising.
During my teenage years,
there was very few things
that I wouldn't place my wiener in.
The ways that--
There's whole Reddit
communities that love that.
The ways that you could find
to masturbate as a teenager
was just, I feel like I could
write a book about that.
I mean, zipity-dooda, zipity.
It probably wouldn't
sell as well as yours.
I have a friend
don't screw up hers.
who had been masturbating
since he was like a little kid,
and the way he masturbated
was to line his stomach
and hump his mattress and have an orgasm
and just feel like done.
I lost my virginity to a
mattress, to my bed actually.
I'll tell you about that in a second.
Go ahead.
No, you just told her.
And then one day, when he was about 13,
he did his usual humping the
mattress feels really good
and all this stuff came out
of his penis and he panicked.
He was sure he had broken something.
So he ran to his mom
and was like, this, oh,
I don't know what happened,
but I'm really worried
that there's a disease or,
and his mother was totally cool about it.
She was like, this is just a
normal part of what happens.
Let's go run the laundry, and
you're gonna be just fine.
This is probably gonna keep happening.
That's one of my favorite stories
of an early masturbation experience
that didn't reinforce
shame but was just like,
yeah, that's normal, that happens.
Because it could have gone another way.
Well, it did with us, we come from--
I never ran to my mom and told
her anything about my jizz.
Right, well, we come from
a conservative evangelical
Christian background that gives
you a certain set of beliefs
about sex that then
you have to deconstruct
as you grow older, but yeah,
the first time I masturbated,
I definitely thought I broke my dick.
I was not about to tell my
mom about it, but then--
You were pleasantly surprised
that it wasn't powder,
you told us last year.
The discovery of the
having sex with the bed,
which if you're listening
and you need any tips,
I will say that you just
find something like a shoe,
and usually two shoes, the
thing about shoes, now,
just roll with me here, is that
a shoe has like a gradation,
like if you get a converse all-star,
if you take the mattress
and the box spring, right?
So you've got the mattress
and the box spring,
you can put the shoes in,
and the further you wedge the shoes in,
it changes the size of the
opening between your mattress
and your box springs, and that's the thing
that you're screwing, by
the way, is that opening,
and you just dial it in--
So you're penetrating the
gap between the mattress
and the bedspread?
Yeah, yeah, so it's
like a sideways vagina.
I hope you're using a lot of loob.
He didn't use any.
Well, here's the thing,
I definitely don't recommend this,
cuz there was a, I mean, I was
like a 15-year-old kid that--
I mean, what happens when
you flip your mattress?
My hands could have
been made of sandpaper,
and it wouldn't have stopped me.
I mean, as a 13-year-old boy,
I was religiously flipping
my mattress every month,
rotate, flip, there's a flip.
No, there's a towel in there.
There's a towel in there.
There's a rotate, then
there's a flip and rotate.
There's a towel in there,
because you don't want your mom
to find that situation,
and don't use your favorite shoes.
Again, the friction just feels
like it's gonna be really high.
Oh, I'm sure it was.
It was probably not healthy,
but nothing could stop me,
nothing could stop me.
You like pleasure spiked with pain
and music is your aeroplane?
One of my favorite things about your book,
which we would actually
like to do right now
if you don't mind, is we would like
to actually take the
sexual temperament quiz.
Okay.
On page 54, I mean,
it's only 10 questions,
but before we--
You can take it along with us,
Well, we'll walk through our answers.
Listener.
That way you can get to know us.
Oh yeah, yeah, as you're listening,
I thought we could read all the questions,
give our answers, then
Emily, you kind of know
where we stand.
Then we can kind of talk that
out and then talk about people
who are, maybe, if we're
the same, different than us
or different than the two of
us, even, if we're different,
but give us some context
for the sexual temperament questionnaire.
Right, so this is a
little Cosmo quiz version
of the actual scientific
instrument that researchers use
to assess what's known
as the dual control model
of sexual response.
So the idea here is that
humans, like all mammals,
have a mechanism in their brain
that controls sexual response,
and it's a dual control mechanism,
which means it has two parts,
and the first part is a sexual accelerator
that a lot of us are familiar with.
It notices all the sex related information
in the environment.
That's everything that you
see, hear, smell, touch, taste,
or crucially, everything you
think, believe, or imagine
that your brain codes as related to sex.
It takes all the information in,
and it sends the turn on signal that many
of us are familiar with.
It's working at a low level right now.
Here we are talking about sex.
This is just a tiny little bit
of sex-related information.
So you're getting just a
little tiny bit of activation
of the accelerator at
a subconscious level.
Fortunately, at the same time,
you have the second mechanism, the brakes.
Noticing all the good reasons
not to be turned on right now.
That's everything that you
see, hear, smell, touch, taste,
think, believe, or imagine
that your brain codes
as a potential threat, and
it sends the turn off signal.
Both of them are functioning all the time.
So your level of arousal at any
given moment is a balance of
how much the ons are turned on
and how much the offs are turned off,
and people have different
sensitivities of these mechanisms.
Most of us are piled up in the middle.
We're just medium in the
sensitivity of our accelerator
and our brakes.
Some people have a really
sensitive accelerator,
which if you drive a car
that's got a really sensitive accelerator,
that's gonna be an experience.
You're gonna do a lot of jerking,
like your head's gonna jerk back.
You're gonna have a high, exactly,
high sensitivity.
Yeah, and if you have a really
low sensitivity accelerator,
like it takes a lot more gas
and a lot more time to get you
where you wanna go,
and some people have a
really sensitive brake.
These are actually the
folks who are the most prone
to sexual dysfunction,
because it turns out the best predictor
of sexual difficulties is
not not enough stimulation
to the accelerator.
It's too much stimulation to the brakes.
Ooh.
So as we go, so I see that there's--
This is a very helpful
way to think about it,
because you talk about this as well,
just the misnomer of sex drive.
Well, let's get back to that.
I don't wanna talk about it yet.
I know, it's great.
I wanna do the test first.
I super wanna talk about that, but so,
and then some people have
a really low sensitivity
of brakes, which even if you're
driving a car that just has
like a regular level of
accelerator sensitivity,
if your brakes are not responsive enough,
some not so great things can happen.
Hmm, right, okay.
So for us,
but most of us are
in the middle.
Well, let's find out.
I see that
there's an inhibitors page five questions,
and so we're supposed to
add up our numbers here,
and then on the other page,
there's an exciters five questions.
So let's just go through 'em,
and then we can, kind of,
flesh this out.
Okay, on a scale of zero to four,
zero meaning not like you at all,
and four, exactly like you, answer this.
Sometimes I have so many
worries that I am unable
to get aroused.
Sometimes I have so
many worries I am unable
to get aroused, zero, not at
all, four, exactly like me.
This is complex, because,
okay, so as someone who
thinks about these things
in the context of a 21 year marriage,
I think about the fact that
stress often makes me want
to go and,
but not necessarily have
an encounter with my wife,
because that can sometimes
be like, or in that scenario,
I've really gotta think about her,
and I've got to make it an
enjoyable experience for her,
and that can seem like work sometimes
when you're already stressed out.
Right, but--
So you've already just told me something
about the sensitivity of your accelerator.
About 10 to 20% of people find that
when their stress is increased,
their interest in sex is increased,
and it will not necessarily
be for partnered sex
or for their relationship
with their long-term partner,
but it will increase their
interest in sexual release,
in porn, or in a higher risk
kind of sexual behavior.
So my guess already is
that you're gonna score
on the higher end of the
sexual excitation scale,
which is the accelerator.
Yeah, so I think--
Because I relate to that, but then also,
when I'm in a stressful
zone, like, oh this week
or these couple of weeks
have really piled up,
I realize that I haven't
thought about having sex.
So definitely in high stress
times I'm like, oh yeah,
now I'll call this a sex dry spell,
Oh, the ol' dry spell
but neither one of those is this.
This is like--
This is about arousal.
I have so many worries that
I'm unable to get aroused.
I think that I can always,
I mean, when I'm in go mode,
it's like, I can usually
compartmentalize and overcome it.
It's just a question of do
I want to come it at all?
But once I've engaged in being there,
I don't get two in my head.
I'm going with one.
So I'm gonna put a one, too.
Next one, unless things
are, quote, just right,
it is difficult for me to
become sexually aroused.
Zero.
Yeah, I'm a very meticulous person and I--
Your house could be burning down.
I, yeah, I'm not gonna, I mean,
you think someone could
be pummeling your, a boxer
Somebody could be actively intruding.
could be pummeling your face.
There could be an intruder
taking my television
and be like, well, hold
on now, priorities, man.
Yeah.
I'm gonna put another one there.
So people who score four
on this are there people
who like, a stray piece
of grit on the sheets,
a stray fingernail, a stray thought,
a stray sound in the hallway
can just shut everything right down.
Those are the people who are fours.
For me, I'm like, if the
dogs are still in the bed,
that's their problem.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
That is their problem.
I am not gonna live in a
world where my dogs dictate
if I'm able to get nooky or not,
and Cristy and I have discussed that.
You haven't trained your dogs?
Barbara knows.
They know something's up.
Barbara knows that mommy and
daddy are doing special time,
and that's when she just
goes into her house.
She like, just so she kinda
like, okay, and then goes
in there and then just
kinda lays down and waits.
Jade, kind of, looks
away, and I'll pick him up
and put him on, we have
couch in our bedroom.
The eye contact is a problem.
I'll put the dogs on the couch and then--
So they can watch?
If they want to, I do not care.
You're an exhibitionist.
That's my thing is that like, and yeah,
Christy is fine with that too,
but if the dog is trying
to crawl up in there
and get in somebody's face,
you're like, what's going on?
It's like, Jasper--
We have a dog like that.
She wants to participate.
Right, so you gotta set her outside.
You just gotta close the door, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, participate.
Yeah, that's a lot.
All right, so--
She just wants to be
right up in there like,
hi, everybody.
Yeah, she sees love happening.
She wants in on it.
Yes, it's like, this is not.
Yes, this looks like a fun game.
Yeah, my dogs, they do tend
to know that something's up.
They do face away.
I think that, I don't know.
They can see and smell a
lot of things we can't.
Right, I think the smell
has a lot to do with it.
If I'm uncertain how my
partner feels about me,
it's harder for me to get aroused.
Okay, I can I'm gonna move up this one.
If I'm uncertain, it's
like, is Christy mad at me?
Or have I done something?
Yeah, I mean,
I want this to be like us
both to be at the party.
You know what I'm saying?
Well, I have this thing that happens.
And I get concerned about that.
Emily, help me understand this.
So I'm gonna put a three for that.
I'm gonna put a one for this
because sometimes, Jessie,
first of all, we have a, what
I call, a high frequency,
low amplitude, conflict
situation in our marriage, right?
You fight a lot, but it's
never really blowout.
We don't build up the resentment,
and then it blows out.
It's just like, we're
constantly, kind of, in love
and also arguing with each other.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's lasted for 21 years,
Yeah, and we're not like that.
and sometimes when she gets
mad at me, it turns me on,
and I don't know what it is,
but she's got an opinion about something,
and she's really getting into it,
and then we're having an
argument about something,
and then I'm just like, oh,
and just something happens,
and I'm kind of turned on.
I don't know what it is,
and we don't do the dom
stuff where we don't,
we haven't experimented with that.
I'm not saying I wouldn't, we
just haven't done that yet.
So it's not like, oh, dominate me,
but it's more you're a little
getting a little feisty.
That's a little sexy right now,
and then she starts laughing,
and then it usually
diffuses the situation.
That's not why I'm doing it.
It's just my natural response.
Am I okay, Emily?
You are.
You're normal.
You're fine.
There could be a couple
of different explanations
for why it happens, and I think
a big part of it is the fact
that your anger is not
escalating to a high level.
You're just a little irritated or annoyed,
and then she is irritated
and annoyed in response,
and first of all, that's a connection.
That's an emotional connection.
You haven't escalated to a place
where you're no longer connected.
John Gottman's research shows that
when people's heart rates get
above 100 beats per minute,
they lose their ability
to listen to each other,
but you're not allowing the
stress levels in your body
to escalate to that point.
You're just getting a
higher level of activation
than usual together, and
am I wrong in thinking
that you enjoy your wife as a person?
You're not wrong.
So here she is being her full personhood.
You are connected together
at a high level of intensity
that is not disconnecting you.
It makes sense to me that
that would be arousing.
There's also--
And that's one
of the reasons I fell
in love with her too.
When we were dating was that
she was passionate about stuff
and it was like, damn, I like that.
So I think I'm just continue
to be attracted to her
in that way.
Yeah, there's another piece of it.
Yeah, for me, it's more about
connection than it is about,
the conflict, to me, is like,
the resolution is what brings
on the horny for us.
It's like making up is that very fun?
Yeah.
So that's very much about attachment.
So the biology of love
is human attachment.
It originates in the fact
that our infants are entirely
dependent on their adult caregivers.
If you leave 'em by the side of the road,
they will just die of exposure
if they're not eaten by a bear first.
Human babies are ridiculous.
They're heavy.
They make a lot of noises.
They smell weird, right?
They're also adorable.
They're uglier
than we care to admit.
I know, adorable, yes.
But, and yet,
when somebody hands you a baby
and is like this one's yours.
Keep it alive.
No matter how frustrated
and resentful you feel,
there is nothing on earth that
will stop you from showing up
to help that baby when
that baby needs you.
That's attachment and around adolescence,
that infant caregiver system gets co-opted
into peer-to-peer relationships.
Now, when you're an infant,
your life literally depends
on your adult caregiver coming
back when you need them.
When you're an adult, that's
not literally the case,
but your body doesn't know that.
So when there is a threat
to your attachment object,
a threat to this attachment connection,
one of the strategies
adults have to reconnect
when there's a threat to
the attachment is sex.
So that's why makeup sex
and even break up sex can be so intense
is it's fueled by this
desperate, oh my God,
I need to fix this attachment
or else I could die.
Wow, damn.
Well, so I gave that a three.
I gave it a one.
You gave it a one.
Okay, if I am worried
about taking too long
to become aroused or to
orgasm, this can interfere
with my arousal.
If I'm worried about taking
too long to become aroused
or to orgasm.
I feel like I'm watching two guys grapple
with a question that women would be like,
oh yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
Well, the interesting thing,
and when you have a penis,
obviously there's lots of signals
that are happening with a vulva and vagina
and everything down there,
but there can be this
like, am I at full mast,
half mast, because there's
such an obvious like,
you're either on or you're off.
I do think that there
could be times like, oh,
this is not happening as fast
as I expected this to happen
or oh, I'm about to, I'm
trying to go longer tonight.
I'm really trying to go for
it tonight to show how great
of a lover I am and oh gosh,
I'm about to lose my erection.
You know?
Yeah.
Those kind of things can
get into your head at times.
So I think I might go with
a good two on this one.
I'm gonna give it a one.
Sometimes I feel so shy or
self-conscious during sex
that I cannot become fully aroused.
I'mma put a zero for that.
Yeah, that doesn't happen for me.
Okay, so that's all we have on that side.
Again, women are all like, really?
Okay, so that was total four there.
Oh, you got a total of four.
And, both of those are
for cultural reasons.
There's nothing innate in being
born in an it's a girl kind
of body that makes a person
self-conscious about their body
or feel shy about sexuality.
That's entirely cultural.
It's cuz we're trained from
birth to hate our bodies
and feel ashamed of our genitals.
Mmhmm.
Boo.
I know, right.
Boo, let's move over to exciters.
I got a total of six there.
You got a total of four for inhibitors.
Did I win?
Same scale zero to four.
I'm very competitive.
I was gonna say, I was like, dang,
cause I took the test too just
to see the female perspective,
and I was like, dang,
that's what they got.
I have a 12 from mine.
12, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we'll come back to that.
So you know what?
You win, unless this is golf and I win.
I win.
And Jenna wins.
If it's traditional sports, Jenna wins.
All right, keep taking it.
Somebody's gotta win.
On the excited side.
In my zero sum world,
Seeing a partner doing something
that shows their talent
or intelligence or watching
them interacting well
with others can make me
very sexually aroused,
zero, not like me, four, exactly like me.
Oh, this is a big one for me, man.
I think somebody can
become much more attractive
when they are demonstrating
their intelligence.
You're talking about hot for teacher?
Yeah.
The tot for teacher dynamic.
And also someone--
Well, maybe that's a different dynamic.
Well, likewise, someone can
become very unattractive
when there's nothing
there except the external.
Yeah, Mr. Bryant was a
great physics teacher,
but there were other things that,
and I liked his sense of humor,
but there were just things about him
that didn't make me horny.
Well, I think it's the
kind of thing that like,
Sorry to bring you into this Mr. Bryant.
you're scrolling through
Instagram and it's not uncommon.
It's not uncommon to see a beautiful woman
on Instagram.
Oh, well, on your for-you page.
Yeah, and yeah, and I
think the algorithm knows
that I like beautiful women,
but then when you go to
the profile and see that,
it seems that the--
The algorithm knows what you
think a beautiful woman is.
The extent of this account
is beautiful woman.
At that point, it's like,
I'm not as attracted
to this person at this point,
but if this person was like--
Couldn't you have a video
of you solving some physics equations?
Yeah.
Mr. Bryant was a physics teacher.
I don't know if I said
that, but yes, okay.
Dissecting a frog.
Mr. Bryant was hot.
So seeing exuding talent or intelligence
or interacting well with
others, I'm gonna put a three.
What'd you put?
I put a four.
Okay, when I think about
someone I find sex,
what'd you put, Jenna?
We'll go one by one this time.
Oh, I put a three, yeah.
Three, okay.
Intelligence
and passionate is, yeah, I like.
When I think about someone
I find sexually attractive
or fantasized about sex, I
easily become sexually aroused.
Oh yeah, four.
I mean, if I'm gonna--
Yeah, what else?
Why would I be fantasizing,
what do I expect is gonna happen?
I mean, what else could
happen if you fantasize?
Help us understand someone, Emily,
who might score that low.
Did you score at low, Jenna?
I did not score low.
Actually, I'm a high
accelerator more than--
Don't skip ahead.
I'm just saying, but.
What number?
I put a three.
All right, three.
You got a Tesla Model S up in there?
Emily, what were you gonna say?
So people with low sensitivity
accelerators are less
likely to fantasize in the first place,
and when they do fantasize,
it's more a traditional
experience of daydreaming
where they're just imagining
that something could happen
without it necessarily being
a really visceral experience.
I don't know that I've ever sat around
and just had a fantasy.
What do you mean?
Are you saying that you've
had a fantasy for the sake
of the utility to be able to masturbate,
and you don't consider that a fantasy?
Because obviously, you've done that.
Like when you're walking down the street
or you're sitting in heavy traffic,
you're daydreaming
letting your mind wander,
and it goes to sexual
things that could happen
or couldn't happen.
That's, okay, yeah.
Okay, well I'll change my to three.
That happens quite a bit.
Yeah, but yeah, yeah.
That makes sense.
If it is possible someone
might see or hear us having sex
it is more difficult
for me to get aroused.
Watch the numbers on this one.
It's reverse-scored.
Reverse-scored, four
means not like me at all.
Zero is exactly like me.
So the scale goes down the
more you relate to this.
If it is possible someone might
see or hear us having sex,
it's more difficult to get aroused.
That's not like me at all.
I mean, we were in the car
going at it and a hiker walks by
and then I was like, just get down,
How close?
Just kinda hide.
We were both down, but right
on the outside of the window,
but the sun had gone down,
and I think the hiker will
probably see a reflection
of themselves, not of--
Were the windows steamy?
Potentially, yeah.
It was early on, though,
in the festivities,
but then another hiker
walks by and another hiker.
It was a freaking cavalcade of hikers.
They were in like a chain.
Well, you should never hike alone, really,
because that's when you get in trouble.
But the more hikers that came by,
the more I was, kind of, into it.
Especially when it's dark out.
What are these?
I don't think they were hikers.
I think it might've been
It was dusty.
Scavengers.
a hookup spot.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was dusk, and they were
wearing hiking attire.
Hiking gear, okay.
They had spent a day on the mountain.
Maybe that's their kink.
I don't know.
So for me,
But your experience
with people walking by,
I put a four.
That's not like me at all,
because that does not make
it more difficult for me
to get aroused.
Whereas another person in that situation,
the first hacker goes
by, and you're like, ah,
and the second person goes
by, and you're like, oh no,
we're done.
Yeah.
Yeah, I put a three on this one.
I downgraded from a four.
We talked on a previous podcast about
how sometimes you'll be
staying in one of those hotels,
and I don't know what
part of the conversation
on the previous podcast was edited out.
So I don't know.
I don't listen back to it,
but all I was saying was that
you're in a high-rise hotel,
and you realize that you've
left the window open,
and then my disposition
is just like, okay,
there's a little bit of an
exhibitionist in me, right?
And then recently speaking of hiking,
We're entertainers.
Jessie and I went on a
hike, and it's Los Angeles.
So you can't get alone on a hiking trail,
but there was offshoots
No banks on these hikes.
on this particular trail,
and I was like, hey, what do you think
about taking a little
offshoot, finding a big rock
or something, and having a little fun,
and she was like, okay, that sounds fun,
but we did not realize that
we had gotten ourselves
in a situation.
Now, first of all, also,
I'm 6'7", she's 5'3".
You do the math on that, and a--
What would that be, subtraction?
Yeah, yeah.
What's your,
Okay, go ahead.
If we were both standing
up on like a creek bank,
and that was when we realized
that the main trail looped
back around and was like 20 feet from us
and saw three heads walking by,
and at that point, I would say
that the reason I immediately
was like, oops, get up, get
up, and she was also like that
was just I just don't want to be,
what if I get recognized man?
And it's just, I don't
want that to be the memory
that someone has of me.
So that's why I'm not
putting a four because--
Right, you don't wanna
educate like a family of.
Yeah.
Somebody calls from the trail, hey, Rhett.
Exactly, yeah,
Awkward.
that's the situation
that I'm not interested
in, but if you're staying
at a hotel that's got thin walls,
and you know that the people can hear you,
my disposition is to get
louder and put on a show
for the people in the next room,
not in an impositional way,
but just like, don't
let that be The reason
that you get quiet.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So I'm gonna go with the three.
All right.
I do wanna point out that
there are a lot of people
for whom the idea of
potentially being caught
or seen is arousing, but the
reality of being in a situation
where they could be caught or seen is not.
It just shuts everything down
and that's totally normal.
It's because the context of
actually being in a situation
where you could be seen
and potentially not safe
is different from the fantasy world
where you can control the idea
that you actually are
totally safe the whole time,
Yeah, that's a good delineation.
But you get to have the idea.
All right, so I'm gonna lower
mine from a four to a three
for that reason.
That's helpful.
Jenna, what did you put?
Well, we have slightly different editions
of the book.
So my quiz is a little
different than yours.
So I don't have that question, but I,
What would you say?
as someone who has done those things
and also been caught in those situations,
Do tell.
I'd say probably like a three.
If I don't get caught, is really fun.
Okay.
Is really fun.
Okay, all right.
Really like it,
but yeah, getting caught, I'm like crap.
This is very embarrassing and mortifying.
The quiz changed from edition to edition,
because people requested that I put in one
that was more inclusive of people,
of every gender and hormone combination.
Therapists in particular
wanted me to make it so
that anybody in a couple
could take the same quiz.
Gotcha.
Is that the one
that we have?
So that's why
they're different.
We've got the new one.
Yeah.
We've got the superioral.
I spent my pandemic
rewriting "Come as You Are".
Yes.
Here's a straightforward one.
Two more to go.
Particular scents are
very arousing to me, four,
exactly like you, one, not at all.
You go in a bed, bath, and body works,
and you gotta,
That's not a place.
what?
It's Bed, Bath, and Beyond
or Bath and Body Works.
Oh.
I mean, you said Bed,
Bath, and Body Works, which
first of all, great colab idea,
because I think that would work.
I think the Venn diagram
is just a circle there.
I'm saying this is not much like me.
I don't really think about, I mean,
we've said on the show
that stink makes me horny.
Maybe think more about body smells.
I about to say, dude,
I put a four because--
I was talking about candles.
No, man, the smell of this,
I mean, let's just, you know,
my biggest disappointment
in goop, and I have many,
is the fact that the
candle that's supposed
to smell like a vagina
doesn't smell like a vagina.
It's just a gimmick.
What does it smell like?
It just smells like a good candle, right?
Like, I don't feel like
there was much effort put.
We had one on the show,
and I'm not saying I've
smelled a lot of vaginas.
It was candle fragrant.
There wasn't any like human
scent in that I could detect.
I'm sure no two vaginas smell the same,
That's correct.
but there's a general sort
of undertone that I think is,
I mean, that's the best
smell in the world, and--
When we talk about stink make me horny.
there's this subversion of
this is an interesting scent
unlike any other scent,
whether it's a vagina
or any other scent, it's
like, oh, this is provocative
versus some other response.
I would go a step further
and say that
I'm still gonna put mine at a two.
I regret the fact that in
modern society we've become
so cleanliness obsessed,
because that whole idea
of somebody stinking a little bit
and it making you horny is like,
that feels like that was the
norm for most of human history
until we started deciding that we had
to always smell completely clean, right?
Aren't we just washing
all our pheromones off?
Isn't that what's happening these days?
Humans don't have pheromones.
Oh, snap!
That's why we bring people
who know what they're talking
about on this, well, actually
we don't very often, but--
Well, let me say that
there is no evidence, yet,
that we have pheromones.
So, ugh, so I can't say, yes,
it's because of pheromones,
What is a pheromone?
people do smell different.
They're like tiny chemicals
that communicate information
about sex, by which I
mean which one you are,
and like for a whole lot of other animals,
the varmora nasal gland
is actively functioning
and perceiving pheromones,
but there's no evidence
that humans actually, we
have a varmora nasal gland,
but there's no evidence that
we're excreting pheromones
for it to detect.
What we can smell when you
smell t-shirts and you can tell
which one is your spouse.
Correct.
What we're smelling is
a combination of things,
but in particular, MHC, which is a factor
in your immune system that says
something about how similar
to you this person's immune system is.
Interesting.
Whoa, and the more similar,
the more attracted?
The opposite, because the more similar,
the more likely you are related.
Ha!
Oh wow, because we did the
thing on the show a while back
and we did a very tame version of it,
but it was based on that study,
which I'm sure you're familiar with,
which is where they gave
people the shirts to smell,
and then what you've found
attractive through smell,
lined up what you found
attractive physically
or I'm sure I'm giving a
bad interpretation of it.
Basically, you could anticipate who you
would be attractive to--
Everybody gives a bad interpretation.
You could anticipate who
you were gonna be attracted
to reliably by just smelling the shirt.
Panties.
And maybe that.
It wasn't panties in this
particular experiment.
I don't know if a study
that does underwear.
I think that would be a
really interesting experiment,
but I don't know of one.
Hey, there we go.
Yeah.
Let's see if we can get bed,
bath, and body works to
sign up for that experiment.
I mean, certain people--
funded by bed, bath,
and body works.
People who put a four would
be lined up around the block.
So what number did you put?
I put a two.
I put a four.
Jenna?
And let me say,
this is one of the single best predictors
of having quite a sensitive accelerator.
Yeah, I'm a four.
Smell is a big, yeah, mmhmm.
He who smelled it, dealt it.
I think about sex a lot when I am bored.
This is the final one.
Make it count.
Zero, not at all, four, exactly like me.
When I'm bored, I definitely
think about sex more
when I'm bored than when I'm not.
I would say three, a lot like me.
I'm gonna put a four
just because I feel like
this has been since I
went through puberty,
it's my default.
If I get bored, it's the first
thing that my mind goes to.
Jenna, what'd you put?
Let's add these up.
I'm a somewhat, yeah.
I think that one isn't in my quiz either,
but, yeah, I think I'm more, if I'm bored,
I usually make up whole
entire romantic scenarios
like the perfect date
someone would take me on,
the whole romance of it,
and I never really get
to just the sex part, I guess.
All right, so let's go through totals.
So on this side of exciter, I got a 14.
Rhett?
I got a 19.
And Jenna, you're up there.
Oh yeah, I'm an 18.
Oh damn, you're an 18.
Okay, so I'm, just to say
these one more time, Emily,
and then maybe you can
lump us into categories
or just tell us how to interpret this.
Make just gross generalizations
about all of us.
I'm six, 14, Rhett?
I am four, 19.
And Jenna, you are?
12, 18.
Wow, these are all,
that's my wife's birthday.
It is.
So what are you gonna do with that data?
So you look up in the graph.
There's an answer sheet that
tells you where your score lies
in terms of low, medium, high
for each of the two scales,
because one of the important things
is the two do not co-vary.
Just because your accelerator
sensitive doesn't mean you're
brake is sensitive or insensitive.
Okay, so in the inhibitors
side with the brakes,
zero to six is low.
So Rhett, both of us are low.
Medium is seven to 13
and high is 14 to 20.
So Jenna is medium.
Yeah, so I'm on the medium, yeah.
Medium.
Okay, so give us a little bit about,
if you're on the low side,
what does that mean if you're
in low inhibitor.
Yeah, when you have a
low sensitivity brake,
what that indicates, mostly,
it means that your accelerator,
regardless of how sensitive it is,
is gonna have an easy time
overpowering your brakes,
and so you'll be motivated to do things
and all the good reasons not
to be turned on right now,
your brain's not particularly convinced
that those are good reasons.
Okay.
So if you see a road closed sign,
you just drive through it.
You're like, there's nobody coming.
It's fine, yeah.
To you to use a crude analogy.
And then on the--
Yeah, with the middle,
the combination of a
middle level accelerator
or a middle level brake and a
high sensitivity accelerator,
that's a good combination for
when a person does not
have adequate coping skills
for dealing with, what I'm gonna call,
maladaptive strategies for
managing negative affect,
when they don't have good
strategies for dealing
with their stress, overwhelm,
exhaustion, depression,
loneliness, they might,
because their accelerator is so sensitive
and their brakes are like, meh,
their accelerator will be like, well,
let's just go do sex because
sex feels really good
and much better than this
uncomfortable emotion I'm
currently experiencing,
and that's when a person is at risk
for having a higher risk
relationship with sexuality.
Okay, and let's talk on
the other side, Rhett,
both you and I are high.
Jenna, what was your number
again on the other side?
She was high.
I'm high, yeah.
You're high too.
So both high exciter.
You're all high, dang.
So maybe the best thing to talk about is
what if there's a mismatch
with our partners?
Cuz I know that Christy would be like,
has much more sensitive
brakes than I've established
that I do.
So it's like, let's just talk about that,
I'll call it an extreme mismatch,
but what's the dynamic there,
and then maybe we can
interpret some of those.
Like if you're in the
middle of you're the same,
but it seems like if you're
both the same, then it's like,
okay, this is easier, but if you're--
Maybe, cuz even if you have
the same sensitivity of both
of these parts of your brain,
what they respond to
might be really different.
Like one of you, your brakes
responds very strongly,
negatively when there is
a risk of being caught,
for example, and the
other one, not so much,
and you, sort of, wanna
incorporate that kind of fantasy
into your relationship.
So it's less about the
sensitivity of the mechanism
than what the mechanism responds to,
Gotcha, but let's talk about
if you're kinda opposites.
but when people have
really sensitive brakes
and not very sensitive accelerator,
those are the folks who are most likely
to turn up in sex therapy offices,
because the slightest little tap
on the brakes can shut everything down,
and what's the first thing
that happens in people's brains
when a slight little
change hits their brakes
and they shut down?
Then they start going, ah, darn it.
I hate when this happens
every single time.
When am I ever gonna get over this?
And does that self-criticism,
does it activate the accelerator
or does it just hit the brakes more?
Hits the brakes more.
Yeah, so you can get into a spiral
of a sensitive brake being
activated, self-criticism
and even relationship criticism,
criticism from your partner of like, man,
why can't you just ignore it?
Why can't you just get over it?
It's not that big a deal.
Let's get back to it,
and everything just shuts down even more.
So simply knowing this
person has a sensitive brake,
a small distraction like
a noise in the hallway,
like kids rattling around in the hallway,
there's a sex researcher
named Peggy Kleinplatz
who interviewed an 80
something woman who said
that the most important
sex accessory was Vaseline.
You put it on the doorknob.
So if that tiny little
thing is gonna distract you,
just know that that's true,
know that that's just
normal for this person
and don't freak out about it.
I was like, well, where is
she inserting the doorknob?
Your children's tiny hands.
Yep, but that is an interesting
interpretation of it.
I would not suggest a doorknob,
but you know, who am I?
Right, well, you're tall
enough to just bend over
and the doorknobs right there.
I could probably get one in my ass.
Make sure it has a flange.
Well, the whole door is the flange.
Question, because I feel like--
I had not been thinking
that viscerally about it.
Thanks for that image.
Okay, Emily, question for you,
because obviously, I scored
very high on this at 19.
However, and I think that my
wife would be medium to high,
and I think that, but she
would also interpret me,
sometimes, as, to use the
misnomer, which we can talk about,
as having a lower sex drive,
because we have a healthy amount of sex.
She does initiate quite
a bit, and I think--
Just for the record, a healthy
amount of sex is any amount
of sex that feels right
for you and your partner.
That's why you're here.
Thank you for clarifying that.
For us, we feel like it's
a healthy amount of sex
that we're both satisfied with,
but I think the thing that happens often,
because we've established
that I'm thinking
about sex quite a bit, and
I'm pretty much ready to go
at any time, but she may
not at times interpret me
in that way, because once we
are engaged with one another,
and I want it to be something
that's not just a quick,
obviously, I can be satisfied
and done very, very quickly
if I wanted to, if I wasn't
taking her into account,
but we don't ever, I mean,
very rarely do we do that.
Do we have, what I would just call,
a traditional quickie.
We've had conversations about
this where she's like, well,
if you want to do that,
then we can up our frequency of quickies,
but I just never feel right about it.
So we go through the process
and then it becomes incredible,
but sometimes there's a
barrier to entry, literally,
of me wanting to engage in that way,
which then is interpreted
by her as a me not wanting
to have sex.
Yeah, so it's like, let's face it.
It's kind of a project to get to the part
where two people are both
in the mood and ready.
Can we talk about responsive
and spontaneous desire?
Yeah.
Yes.
Cause I feel like, especially
with a high excitation score
and a medium to low brakes score,
you're probably people who
experience spontaneous desire
for sex where it just,
sort of, out of the blue,
Erika Moen is the cartoonist
who illustrated "Come as You Are",
and she draws spontaneous
desire as a lightning bolt
to the genital.
Just kaboom, oh, I would
like to have some sex, ah,
and you're like, you
take your lightning bolt
to your partner, and you're like, ah?
That's spontaneous desire,
and your partner may
or may not be there at that time,
but that is one of the normal,
healthy ways to experience desire.
Another healthy, normal
way to experience desire,
the research calls responsive desire
where instead of it being
just a lightning bolt
out of the blue, you setup date night,
you get childcare, you go
to a bed and breakfast,
you make plans, you show up in the moment,
you put your body in the bed,
you let your skin touch
your partner's skin,
and your body and your
brain go, oh, right.
I really like this person.
I really like this, and
then you get the kaboom,
and that's responsive desire
where spontaneous desire
emerges in anticipation
of pleasure, responsive desire emerges
in response to pleasure,
and what you've done is
you've created a context
where your accelerator is
activated and your brakes,
all that stuff that hits the brakes,
the body image stuff and
the stress and being stuck
in parent mode or work mode
or whatever else you do mode
that is very far away from erotic mode,
you can leave that all behind.
You close the door and
all those other parts
of your identity stay behind.
That creates a context
where your brake is freed up
and your accelerator
can go, and we are busy.
We have a lot of other things to do,
Yeah, for real.
and it generally takes
preparation and effort
to create that context
where you don't have to be
in parent mode and distracted
and in house-holding mode
and distracted and work
mode and distracted.
So when it feels like a
project to get to the like,
I wanna be really present for my partner,
I wanna be able to like pay attention
to the ways we're connecting,
it actually does take effort.
That is normal.
You are doing it right if that
is the way you experience it.
And okay, I relate to
this in a number of ways.
First of all, talking about
like vacation getaway sex
is like it can be absolutely
amazing and there's like, okay,
we set aside this time,
we're looking forward to it,
we're going away for two nights,
childcare's taken care of,
this is about us connecting,
we know like the moment
we get in the room,
we're gonna have at it,
and then we're gonna have
at it a few more times
as many times as we can.
This is like the focus of our getaway.
Back-to-back?
How long do you have to wait?
Front-to-front, back-to-back.
No, how long do you
have to wait in between?
I mean, we're not teenagers anymore.
The perfect amount of time for us, Rhett.
The healthy amount of time for us.
Come on, but if it was a competition.
I just think answering that
question doesn't help anybody.
It's not a competition,
but I will say it is
actually true that around 18,
your testosterone levels peak,
your sensitivity to it peaks,
and so your refractory period,
which is the amount of time it
takes you to get an erection
after the last time you ejaculated,
that refractory period begins to lengthen,
and then the reliability of
your erections gradually begins
to go down as you get into
the, sort of, menopause age.
Right.
So that's real.
So yeah, as you move through
your 40s and into your 50s,
and hopefully you live a
long and erotic life deep
into your 80s and 90s,
your erections are gonna
become less reliable
and that's fine.
Erections come and go, and
they are no more important
than you decide to make them.
But back to the vacation sex for a sec.
Right, just saying.
All right, so it's like,
we can have this amazing experience,
and then it's like, okay,
why can't we just have that
when we're back at home?
Every night.
Of course, the answer
is the context of life,
but one of the things that we'll
do is sometimes we're like,
we'll be having sex, and we
will have a conversation about
how great it is.
We'll be like, why did we put this off?
This is the most amazing thing
that's happening right now,
and then I start saying things like,
let's commit right now to doing
this again tomorrow night,
and I'm having this like--
But you also do that with
things other than sex.
Anytime you're in a group of people
that are having a good time,
you stop and make everyone
acknowledge how good
of a time we're having and be like,
we have to plan the next one right now.
I just think it's like,
let's make our decision about
the next time we align based
on this moment.
Let's remember to factor this moment in,
and let's weight it properly.
This is one of the most
amazing experiences
that we can have.
Why did it take longer than we both--
And I listened to your
virginity episode, it's free.
Yeah, oh, you did.
Yeah, okay.
I did my research.
Hey, look, I read your book.
We're all on the same page here.
You didn't have to do that, but it's free,
and it isn't, right?
Yeah, so there's actually an evidence base
to what you're doing, which
is the research on savoring,
and there are parts of what you're doing
that actually do increase the
pleasure that you experience
in the moment, and it shapes your memory.
You're creating more of
what in "Inside Out",
the Pixar cartoon, they call
core memories where you stop
and you talk to other people
about how great this is.
You notice the sensations
that are happening
and how enjoyable they are.
You compare it to like,
man, those other poor saps
who don't get to experience that.
I feel so sorry for them.
There's all kinds of
skills that you can employ
to make this moment.
You capture it in a photograph
so that you can return
to it really easily, and that
means that when you look back
on your life, you've just, sort
of, accumulated peak moment
after peak moment after peak moment,
and your life feels, both,
like it has been more worth living
and like it has been longer.
A part--
Nice, I love that idea
of a mental photograph and like I have a
whole pornographic drawer of that.
A movie in your head.
Yeah, from my practice.
Yeah, and the part that's
not evidence based is we need
to start planning the next one now.
Yeah, I--
What about scheduled sex?
Oh, we do that.
Monday night is sexy time.
There's lots of, we don't
do it every single week,
but we'll do it.
I mean, there's lots of
times where it's like,
if I'm like, hey, you want to go for it?
And then there's like, well,
we're not in alignment,
or sometimes it's like we
feel like it's been a while,
and we're like, I feel
like shit right now.
I'm not in the mood, but let's
set a date that we can look
forward to two nights
from now or whatever.
We do that all the time, and I feel like
then we're each able to
prepare in our own way,
and also, the expectations are aligned.
So it's not like me walking
up with a lightning bolt
and springing it on her.
That's what you call it?
That's what a Emily calls it.
There's two answers, really.
I recommend scheduled sex all the time.
Like I said, we are busy.
Anything, not on my
calendar doesn't happen.
So I schedule sex, cuz especially
when I'm traveling a lot
on the road, and also, just
because you scheduled it
doesn't mean it's gonna happen.
There have been times when
I was on the road traveling,
and I would get home, and I
have this little window of time
with my husband, and it's
scheduled, and I show up,
and I put my body in the bed,
and I just cry and fall asleep,
cuz I'm so stressed and exhausted.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yes.
And fortunately I'm married to one
of the best human beings
on the face of the earth,
and he's just like,
No you're not, I am.
she clearly needs that more.
Gotcha.
One of the best human beings
on the face of the earth.
They're tied for the best.
They're all tied.
Maybe there's somewhere deep
inside him a part of him
that's like, oh, I don't get sex,
but he has never expressed that to me,
and he's always really
kind and considerate,
and the fact that he is
so kind and considerate
in that moment, that
builds a like, next time,
I'm gonna be even more
ready and enthusiastic,
because he's so understanding and kind.
and sweet and affectionate
That understanding
is so sexy.
and loving.
It is so hot the way that he
doesn't criticize or judge me
for being too tired to have sex.
Oh, that's great.
Well, and you know, cause
we schedule, I think,
and I'm not a scheduler in general.
So I think there are
people who think like me,
and my wife is even less
of a scheduler than me,
would be like, oh, that
takes some of the spontaneity
out of it, but the fact that is that
Absolutely, yeah.
The romance out of it.
we schedule fun things all the time.
Like you say, we are going
to Disneyland on Saturday,
and it doesn't mean you
don't enjoy Disneyland
because you have a ticket
and you've set aside the day.
It's like the only way I
can enjoy Disneyland is
if we make a decision
right now to go and like,
I don't know!
Do we have tickets?
I don't know, let's figure it out!
In some ways, that can be
Pull your pants down!
a horrible experience.
So I definitely don't think
scheduling is not sexy at all,
even as someone who has
difficulty scheduling things,
including sex.
Yeah.
You should see Christy's planner.
Boy, I think that might make
her more horny than anything.
I mean, just a well appointed calendar.
Yes, that was the joke in 30
Rock when Liz Lemon wanted
to get pregnant, when she was like,
if I schedule it and plan it,
and the way she could make
trying to get pregnant sexy was
like the fact that she had
to manage so many calendars
in order to get it done.
Right, yeah.
But scheduling can backfire.
So suppose you set the date,
Saturday at three o'clock,
you me and the red underwear,
and one person sees that
date coming and is revving
up to the time, and the
other person is like, ugh,
it just feels like such an obligation,
and I'm gonna show up, and
they're gonna expect me
to perform in a certain way,
and just it's too much pressure,
and it doesn't seem like it's gonna work.
So scheduling does not work for everyone,
but I do have a friend who
the couple was very stressed.
They were working on a political campaign,
and it was approaching election time.
So they were both just like,
and they would never have sex
if they didn't schedule it,
and it even got to the point,
so they got these dice, like
the silly dice that you roll,
and it tells you to do something,
and it did not cause
them to have more sex,
but it caused them to
spend an hour and a half
on Saturday morning playing together
and talking about intimacy,
and that sustained an erotic connection
through this incredibly
stressful season of their lives,
and that's worthwhile too even
if you're not having genital contact
or doing something that counts
in your mind as having sex.
Erotic play together,
play is the primary
friendship social behavior.
Playing together in that way helps
to sustain the connection even
when other things don't feel available.
Well, that's good.
That's context.
Let's get back to the sex
drive thing that you mentioned
at the top.
So sex drive is not a thing?
Yeah, so I am not delusional.
I know that sex drive is a
very pithy, easy thing to say,
but a sex drive means
a very specific thing.
Biologically a drive is
like thirst and hunger.
There is an uncomfortable
internal sensation that is like,
aooga, aooga, red flashing
lights as it pushes you out
in the world to go solve a problem,
and if you don't solve the problem
of getting adequate hydration
or adequate food or even, yes,
adequate sleep, you
have have a sleep drive,
what happens?
You die.
You literally die, yes.
That's a drive.
Sex is not one of those.
Nobody ever died because
they couldn't get laid.
Nobody ever even got sick,
because they couldn't get laid,
but what sex is is a sexual
incentive motivation system,
and I know sex drive is
so much easier to say.
We're gonna keep saying sex drive,
but let's understand in our hearts
that we mean an incentive
motivation system
instead of an uncomfortable
internal state that pushes you
to go fix the problem.
It is a pleasurable internal
state that pulls you
towards some attractive external stimulus.
I always think of bugs bunny
being pulled on a hand of steam
toward an apple pie in a window.
Woo, woo, what's that?
Woo, I would like to go get more of that.
Sex is one of those, and
it's important, first of all,
to recognize that no one is going
to literally die without sex.
People do literally die
of hunger, for example,
which is why if someone
steals a loaf of bread
to feed their family, we can
feel like, yeah, I get that,
but if someone touches
someone else's sexual body,
because they hadn't gotten
laid in a really long time,
it is not because they were starving.
It's because they were really curious.
So that's invalid.
About the other person's
sexual body, yeah.
That's a great way of
clarifying exactly how you parse
that from a moral ethics standpoint too.
That's very helpful.
Right, an incentive motivation
system is just as natural,
it can feel just as urgent.
We've all, but curiosity
is the ultimate analog
to horniness.
You're just like, I just
wanna know more about that.
I wanna get closer.
I wanna explore it with
every sense that I have.
That's curiosity, and we all know, also,
that there are times in life
when you are more curious
and times in life when
you are less curious,
and that's not a problem.
That's just the impact that context has
on which motivational systems
are most important right now.
Wow, I want to get your,
since when you speak,
unlike when Link speaks or when I speak,
you say things that are informed
and based on extensive education.
So while we got you here,
we're gonna keep asking you questions.
Yeah, and it's strange to me
because we're the same age.
I think about what my
life trajectory has been
in parallel to your,
like, we were in college
at the same time, and
then y'all got married,
and I stayed in school until I was 29.
Well, you know what, it's paying off.
For all of us, it's paying off.
Okay, asexuality, which
has become something
that we've heard so much more about that.
When I was a teenager, I
didn't even know it existed.
So one interpretation of
it would be like, okay,
well, is someone who
considers themself asexual,
are they just someone who is just,
they've got the parking brake
on on the inhibition scale?
Or is that not a helpful
way to think about that?
Because that feels like it's some,
like in other words--
Like it's a problem.
That is, in fact, factually incorrect.
That's what I thought too the
first time I was beginning
to learn about asexuality,
but there's research on this,
about the sensitivity of the
accelerator and the brakes
of folks who identify as
asexual, which is about 1%
of the population in North America,
and it turns out it is not
that they have a more
sensitive accelerator,
or not that they have
a more sensitive brake.
It is that they have really
insensitive accelerators.
Got it.
It takes so much sex-related
stimuli to get their accelerator going.
In fact, there's an asexual sex educator
named Aubrey Lancaster who
uses the analogy of Disneyland.
Oh, well, just like we
can't get enough of that.
Just like me.
Yeah, if you are married to a Disney fan,
God help you.
and they just love,
love going to Disneyland.
They could go to Disneyland
every day, and you're like, oh.
You can go to Disneyland sometimes.
Now I really relate to it.
Now I completely understand,
cuz I'm a Disney-sexual
or whatever the proper term would be.
But because it matters to your partner
on a limited number of
times, you will go with,
because it's fine, and
then you need a long break
before you go back again,
because that's enough.
Asexuality is--
But I have been to the corn dog castle,
and I will say that that can
turn a trip to Disneyland,
that can completely turn
the day around for me,
the corn dog castle.
I don't know what that is.
It's just a place that sells corn dogs.
It's not a ride
At Disneyland?
It's literally just corn dogs.
It's the best part of Disneyland.
They're giant.
They're wonderful.
I'm sure that fits in
the metaphor somewhere,
but I'm not exactly sure how.
Yeah, I don't know.
It could look like a dildo.
I don't know.
I'm working at it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know what's happening.
But asexuality is very varied.
There are sex favorable
ase folks who are like,
I mean, okay.
The main thing about asexuality
is you don't feel sexual
attraction to people.
It's not that your
sexual response mechanism
doesn't function.
A lot of ase folks masturbate.
Some don't.
It's that you don't feel that attraction.
So you're not drawn to the person,
but if your partner really
wants, you're like, yeah, okay,
and it's fine.
Other folks are sex-averse
where the idea of having sex
is actively disgusting to them,
and they don't want any part of it.
So it's a very diverse community.
My favorite thing about ase folks is
that they're entirely non-judgmental.
They're very much about
like, let me explore
what feels right and good for me,
and they often come up with
great terms, demisexual,
gray-sexual as well as asexual.
Quasexual is my favorite term.
Qua as in the french what, like,
or you're just like, I dunno Quasexual.
Okay, if we go back to people
who they're like, I don't know.
We talked about those categories,
but if we go back to like,
all right, I'm in, again,
I definitely don't wanna
use the term normal.
I know that's not what
I'm looking for here.
No, you're just sexual.
But if you like sex,
if you're more sexual,
you talked about a bike analogy,
which if I remember correctly, well,
remind me of what the bike analogy is.
Maybe you don't remember either.
Nobody ever needs to ride a bike?
Yeah, yeah, but--
Is it in the orgasm chapter?
I think that's right.
I think what I took from
it was everybody does.
You don't have to ride a bike,
but if you want to ride a bike, you can,
and if you want to really enjoy it,
if that's a priority of
yours to ride a bike, well,
you can learn how.
You can enjoy it.
You can experience the
thrill of riding a bike
if you want to and if you really--
If you're motivated enough.
So, to me, there's this thing about--
What about a Peloton that
just is a stationary bike.
Sure, that too.
Does that change it?
But it's like it's not, oh, well,
everybody needs to ride a bike,
or everybody needs to
experience bike riding
in the same way, but there
is part of the analogy
that's like, if it's a priority of yours
to experience bike riding,
then there's also a good amount
of work that goes into it.
You're investing yourself
to realize that enjoyment.
That it takes learning.
It doesn't just happen spontaneously.
The first time you try, so in the context,
for example, of learning
how to have an orgasm
for the first time, cuz
you've never had an orgasm,
a lot of people judge
themselves if they need
to use a vibrator, for example,
or just that it's been
so long in their life,
and they still haven't
learned how to do this thing,
that criticism and judgment of yourself,
it just hits the brakes and
makes it even more difficult
to access pleasure.
So you're just gonna
not judge and be like,
you know what?
This takes practice.
I never got practice.
People told me I wasn't
allowed to ride a bicycle,
and now I am learning from
scratch how to do this,
and so hopefully maybe
you'll have a spotter.
Maybe you'll have training wheels,
and you'll go through the
process of gradually learning,
and when you learn to ride
a bike, you might be like,
all right, I did it, and then you're done,
or you might be like, this is amazing,
and I'm going to ride a century now.
Right, well--
To me, just the investment
in my sex experience,
and that aspect of me and
Chrissy's relationship
is something that we both
learned that we need to work at.
It's like, okay, where is it?
Where does that fit in our priorities?
And sometimes you gotta
analyze and make sure
that your actions reflect that.
So that's why I love coming
back to this for the second year
in a row, as I think I said
last week, is that acknowledging
that it's work, and
then if you're into it,
and it's a priority of
yours, it can be worth it.
I think regardless of where you are
and what your particular situation is,
I think one of the reasons that this,
not only are these
conversations fun and just lots
of jumping off points for comedy,
which is what we're doing here,
but also and more
importantly, is that I think
that information and
communication are all, in my mind,
they're always good.
Like when you talk about
the subject of sex,
and we're getting the actual
information from someone who,
evidence-based approach to this stuff,
this is ultimately, it
doesn't take away the sexiness
to make it science-y, to
make it scientific, right?
Well, if you're in my brain,
it makes it way more sexy.
Exactly, and so being able
to learn these things,
and then, what I hope
comes from us talking
about these things, is I know
us having this conversation
will lead to me and Jessie
having a conversation
about the things that we talked about
and having those conversations
that involve fact-based,
evidence-based information.
I've never seen engaging in that way lead
to a negative outcome.
It always seems to move
in the positive direction
when we get more equipped
with more information,
and we continue talking about it.
That's what we always
talk about is that for us
in our friendship, communication
has been so instrumental
and people are like, well,
how are you still working
together after all this time?
How are you still friends
since first grade?
It's like, well, there's ups and downs,
but you have to keep talking about it,
and we approach our
marriages in the same way,
and hopefully you can take the
information that we've gotten
from Emily today and then apply it
to whatever situation you are,
and there's so much more information.
You've got this book.
You've got your previous book.
Where can people get
everything they need to get
from Dr. Emily Nagoski.
Well, reading the books is
always a great place to start.
There's "Come as You Are"
and the "Come as You Are" workbook.
If you find that stress
is really interfering
with your sexuality, that's
the reason I wrote "Burnout"
with my identical twin sister,
because she literally
ended up hospitalized
because of burnout stress,
and I'm about to launch a
"Come as You Are" podcast
from Pushkin Industries
that launches in November,
and I'm currently--
Nice, you're working
with that Malcolm Gladwell.
He shows up at every meeting.
He has some great questions about orgasm.
Okay, cool.
And I'm currently
finishing a book about sex
in long-term relationships
called "Come Together".
Oh, there you go.
That'll be out next summer.
Yeah, we're ready for that one.
I wanna see the cover to that one.
It's actually interesting.
The very first chapter
is called, Why Have Sex?
And you were talking about
like putting work into it
and like, why put the effort
into doing this, frankly,
pretty silly, ridiculous,
sometimes very important,
sometimes a little messy,
often very silly thing
that we humans do?
Why do we do it?
Talking to your partner,
why do we do this?
What does it bring to our relationship?
Can't wait, Jenna, what
about you, closing thoughts?
My kind of closing thoughts were just
how wonderful this book and
just allowing the conversations
about sex can be so helpful,
cuz I'm in my 30s now,
and I read your book when I turned 30,
like right around when I turned 30,
and it was one of those
things I began reflecting on
as a person who grew up being
raised female and with that,
all those connotations that come with it
and how much reflecting I did
on being a high accelerator,
medium brakes and realizing
the coping mechanisms I used
in my early 20s because of those things
and how I wish I had
this kind of knowledge
when I was in my early 20s,
because there certainly was
reckless and toxic behavior
in my sex life and in my
relationships in general.
So I just loved reading this and yeah,
I refer it to anyone I can,
especially how Lily was given
the book, Link, that you said,
and I've given the book
to a girl that's, kind of,
she's kinda like a younger
sister, mentee kind of thing,
family friend, who's in college as well,
and we've had those discussions,
and it just feels really
nice to have those people
and be able to express that
in such a way, I guess,
and I didn't have that.
I didn't have that, and
I really like being able
to talk about it now
and encouraging others
to talk about it.
So yeah, that's my closing thoughts.
Totally agree.
I didn't have it easier, and
that is why I wrote the book.
So I'm thrilled to hear that.
Thank you so much.
Thanks so much for your work.
Doing great work, Emily.
Thank you.
Thanks so much
for spending some time talking with us
and putting up with our rabbit trails.
It's been a total delight.
That was a splendid time.
Yes, it was.
I'm excited about that podcast.
I mean, now I'm gonna have
to have two sex podcasts
that I've listened to.
I'm gonna have to listen to sex with Emily
and the Come as You Are
podcast when that comes out,
and that book about long-term
relationships come with me.
Is that what she said it was?
Love it.
"Come Together"?
Cuz that's what we've got,
long-term relationships.
Next week, we're gonna
be hearing from you.
So let's see how that goes.
The sex talks continue
for one more episode.
Use #EarBiscuits now to give
us responses or of course,
you can always leave us a voicemail,
1-888-earpod1.
Earpod1.
See you next week.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
This is Amber from Austin, Texas.
I just finished listening to the episode.
How much do we know about
orgasms with Dr. Emily Morris?
I grew up in a very
religious Christian home,
and I was sexually
repressed, which is something
that I'm still struggling
to overcome to this day.
I had never heard of Dr. Emily before,
and I learned some great things
from her on your podcast.
So thanks again.
I love you all, bye.
Hey, you guys, thank you so much
for the episode with Dr. Emily Morris,
and I wanna particularly
say thank you to Jenna
for speaking so openly about women's sex.
I'm a 49-year-old female and thought I was
in a pretty good group,
but she did make some really
great points about the shame
that you feel about certain
things and the pleasure.
That was one of the most
enlightening episodes I've
ever heard you guys do,
and this is too long a message
for you to put on the air.
I listen to you all the time,
but Sex-tember actually means something.
I've learned a lot.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
You know what?
I just gotta say I just absolutely
love and adore you guys.
You guys have been part of my
life for 10 plus years now,
and you are the greatest
YouTubers that I've ever known,
and I just love you guys
for being true, down south,
awesome dads, awesome
husbands, great people,
and I just love you guys and that's all.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.